plus grand et plus pratique hf
prévention franchi une nouvelle étape
avec ses locaux si tu attrapes
l'association spécialisée initialement
dans la prévention du sida et les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
poursuit aussi le développement de ses
activités
l'idée c'était d'avoir un siège national
pour hf prévention alors nous sommes
toujours à l'institut de promotion de la
santé pour l'ile-de-france ouest mais
effectivement le ciel nationale
multiplie ses actions des nouveaux
concepts le cardiaque cardiovasculaires
donc tout ce qui va être aussi associée
à la nutrition
le diabète toujours la santé sexuelle et
c'est vrai que pour le coup il y avait
une vraie nécessité d'avoir un siège
national qui puisse effectivement se
développer et développer les actions
partout en france présente sur le
terrain depuis plus de 10 ans auprès des
populations à risque dans les quartiers
et différents lieux de vie hf prévention
est devenu un acteur incontournable de
la lutte contre la transmission des
maladies chroniques et des affections de
longue durée
l'association est également connu pour
ses innovations comme l'application tu
peux trouver un préservatif une première
en france lancée en 2014
elle est aussi à respecter pour son
travail avec les différents acteurs de
la santé
la particularité d'hachette prévention
ceux qui vont sur le terrain ils vont
dans les lieux de drague extérieur et à
l'heure actuelle
y a plus grand monde qui va dans ces
lieux là parce qu'il faut y aller il
faut il faut connaître les lieux il faut
il passer du temps il faut aller à la
rencontre des gens et c'est pas très
facile pour poursuivre ses actions
locales dans l'ouest parisien hf
prévention conserve ses locaux situés à
l'institut de promotion de la santé de
saint quentin en yvelines